do you remember the moment when
filmmaking was no longer a dream and had
actually become a reality for you
remember do you remember that
realization or I've had several stages
of realizing that it's still happening
sometimes I wake up in the middle of the
night and I'm like wow I'm being paid to
make movies that's good
that's that's a good thing but honestly
that that one click never really there
was never really one click of the dream
is now a reality and I think it really
has to do with the fact that I guess
I've always known subconsciously that
it's all about just making stuff it's
all about just making art and you can do
that whether or not someone's paying you
to do it you can it's just something
that you do and I've always done it so
in a weird way this has been going on
since Mark and I were kids
we're just happen to be doing it at
studios and at HBO right now and it
sounds like - it goes back to what you
said there's no set path and there's no
set path yeah and it it almost seems
like is it some way a curse to kind of
say okay yeah I've made it and because
in in Hollywood whether it's whatever
job it is whether you're makeup artists
whatever you're only kind of as good as
your last job yeah I don't feel like
I've made it at all and I don't I don't
know if anybody feels like they've made
it because you could easily never do
another movie again
no one will guarantee you a movie even
if you have a three-picture deal with
the studio they're not necessarily gonna
make it they're just gonna look at it
you know so I think you know it all just
comes down to
you just have to make your stuff and
believe in yourself and and and keep
doing it you know at any level whether
it's a ten million dollar studio movie
or a $40,000 Kickstarter project
you